hey I gotta beat my hedge fund a you
know 6 a.m. to start before everybody
else starts so I wake up to an alarm at
4:30 I get my car with caffeine
cortisol's running sympathetic stays up
I'm in traffic I'm swearing at people I
get to the office I'm late I do all this
stuff and then I'm like all it's noon
I've got to get my workout in so I run
down to a CrossFit gym I blast an
11-minute metcon crush you give
everybody a high five get back to the
office finish wear it get back in
traffic go home and then I wonder why I
feel like I'm diseased because I can't
sleep
Michael Blevins in the building how you
doing man I'm good man thanks for having
me Chris I appreciate it really happy to
have you on we've got one of our mutual
friends out with you at the moment right
we do Elodie yeah Allosaurus all the way
down Newcastle to where are you where
are you based I'm in Salt Lake City Utah
cool which is a strange place to visit I
guess if you were in Europe and you're
thinking about coming to the States it's
not generally the destination that
you're thinking of it's usually East
Coast West Coast the middle area
admittedly is not that interesting but
Salt Lake seems to be kind of a sweet
spot I kid yeah it just seems to be I
don't know what it is about it it's it's
pretty here as high desert you know high
altitude there skiing if you're into
that there's a lot of outdoors you're
three minutes away from like Red Rock
desert
so it's pretty good yeah leds leds a
little bit of a wonder luster isn't she
so I'm not surprised that she's ended up
on you on your doorstep so yeah how
would you describe your approach to
fitness ooh I tend to run away from it
but I have to kind of asterisk that I I
run away from the fitness industry
fitness I think is really important
because it's kind of our last attachment
to what it is to be human
right like before we become all so
technologically advanced that we have
robots throwing food down our throat and
all entertainment is LED screen and all
all senses or sense you know through
some other machine I think it's it's
kind of the expression of being in your
body your mind it's kind of a
combination of maybe I don't you know
how weird you want to get but it's it's
kind of like a spiritual experience when
you express it appropriately and I think
my approach to fitness is providing that
experience for people providing like the
idea that this is an all-encompassing
philosophy that influences other parts
of your lives isn't it interesting that
a lot of people use
video games social media etc etc as a
escape from reality incarnation marks
and now you're offering people an escape
to reality with Fitness that's a really
good way to put it I would say and I
would I would I would kind of bookmark
that for a really deep conversation
about what it is to actually sense
something we are here this is the deep
conversation Michael let's fall down the
rabbit hole my friend alright so there's
something to this experience and how I
framed this for people because people
are very I don't know how to put it
because I don't want to people's initial
belief is that what I see what I hear
what I feel is reality right but in
reality that's not that's not it at all
so what I sense is an interpretation of
certain signals wavelengths patterns
particles that my brain translates for
something that I can make sense of so
the the color is green but that's just a
wavelength spectrum in reality what is
that what does that actually exist or
are we already in a sort of virtual
reality and by putting on virtual
reality through our reality
we're just devolving into one level of
abstraction so how I first like to think
about it and this is a nightmare
situation for me this is like this is
claustrophobia inducing and I like to
say you know imagine that you yourself
your body with all your senses we're
locked into a twelve by twelve by twelve
by twelve box and it was completely dark
there is no light but the outside world
exists around it how long do you think
it would take you before you start
trying to interpret what's going on
around like you hear a car pass so the
echoes and the ricochets of sound you
start to echolocate and eventually
actually very quickly your body through
an act of synesthesia would start
echolocating and you would start getting
visual perception of what's outside of
your
black box and this is what happens with
people that learn how to echolocate
after being blinded or something like
that they can actually navigate a
three-dimensional world based off of
sound and ricochets and noises because
they've taught their brain to
reinterpret their own reality so it
becomes kind of a sonar thing and every
human has a capacity to do this in the
same sense if you are missing something
whatever taste hearing the senses take
over and you'll you'll make a map of the
world like our our our reality is
whatever the map we make of the world
but the map is not the territory hmm so
the best way I like to put this is like
actually that that that black room that
is reality you are already that your
brain is in a blacked out container and
all it's doing is interpreting the world
around it and you sometimes you get
there wrong have you looked at David
White's work I have not right so you're
describing what David White has arrived
at so anyone that wants to find out a
little bit more about this stuff just
search david white on making sense by
sam harris it is episode 184 which came
out earlier this earlier this year oh is
this the author of the case against
reality yes yeah okay so I am familiar
with oh yeah so you know what what he's
saying is is a real serious
manifestation of what you're talking
about
the world as we see it could be
completely different and he is likely to
be really different but because we have
to survive we've managed to interpret it
in a way that allows us to survive so I
get that I like I like that approach I
think it's interesting yeah is it useful
a question that's the guess what I was
about to bring you back to so we got
okay we've got Fitness we've got this
this bringing back to reality what is
reality all this stuff but at the end of
the day what does it matter if what we
see is a true representation of what is
out there when we don't have any other
way than the way that we do have to see
that so I totally agree the utility of
it for me
and through Fitness specifically comes
when I say all of these are just
representations of reality but how good
you are at interpreting that has to do
with your sensitivity right so the more
sensitive I am with faulty tools
admittedly like my eyesight is faulty my
memory is faulty my taste my touch my
hearing
you know I literally ran past somebody
the other day and I thought they called
me an [ __ ] and I was like what did
you say and they're like all I said I'm
sorry and I was like [ __ ] fall to that
um that's I've thought a lot about that
I was like most people calling you
enough so as you're running best well
because I think in in my model of the
world I've built a model where the
majority of people I run into are not
worth knowing and I don't give them the
benefit of the doubt I'm actually on the
negative side of it and it's something
I've had to like really work after to
really correct that thinking because I
want to become more sensitive to other
people so I've started this drill
because I realized you know when driving
in traffic if somebody cuts you off
you're like ah Berg flip that person off
give them whatever it ruins to be kind
of like people are so stupid and in
reality that's not true people are not
stupid human beings are highly
intelligent they just sometimes lack
attention towards my personal well-being
which makes me think derogatory things
about that person but if I remap the
situation that they didn't cut me off
because they're against me that goes
towards nah whatever race or it is I
can't remember but the thought is do not
tribute my life thought which can be
attributed to stupidity exactly so if I
if I go back to that model and I go okay
first attribute a different thing they
cut me off because they're in a hurry
right they're late for something what if
that lateness was you know their
daughter was in the hospital and this is
like a drill that a lot of people do and
then now suddenly they come even now I
want to get out of the way it helped
that person out and so it remodels the
world so I want to become more sensitive
to those interactions and fitness is
just a way to become more sensitive to
the world around you
because you've become more sensitive to
your output input right what the
environment I'm in my heart is racing
the weight is heavy I don't want to do
the activity my brain is working against
me all of these conversations and inputs
and outputs I have to start to manage
and that's something that we don't
practice so we lose our sensitivity with
the you know the model of the world that
we're viewing and I think the more you
get into fitness
the more sensitive you are to reality
why is Fitness the answer to that why
can't I do it through something else
what's so special about fitness mostly
because it's the glasses that I see
through so I'm applying my bias through
most people it could be if I was
speaking to an artist
they might say this is obviously art
that's the thisn to do this a person I'm
gonna do I'm gonna steal man my own
argument here with your argument I would
say that the visceral feelings that you
get especially when you do high output
Fitness um but then again I can go on
the other side of that and say Pilates
yoga especially in yoga slow things that
essentially it's just mindful stretching
there's some very very present states
that you get into there but there's no
hiding being 180 bpm heart rate right
there is nowhere to hide there's nowhere
to hide when you're picking up anything
over 70 percent of your max on a dead
rat does you know that it's happening it
brings you into the present and I did a
podcast with Paul bloom psychologist
University Yale beast absolute beast and
his new book is talking about why people
like pain so how pain and meditation
basically how what is there is
similarity between BDSM and meditation
what do they have in common and there's
this quote from a really famous
dominatrix that said nothing catches
attention like a whip and you know the
point is the reason that people do these
extreme sporting events BASE jumping
that flying squirrel thing I don't know
what that is and like the reason that
they do all of that stuff is because use
the line between you and death is so
fine and and so at the forefront of your
experience you can do nothing but think
put all of you into
that particular experience and I wonder
how much of these you know as you talk
in these sort of almost allegorical
symbolic ways about your fitness I
wonder how much of that experience is
you bringing yourself into the present
be making it a meditative experience
because there's nowhere to hide well a
lot of it yes is presents and I find you
know maybe the the easiest most tangible
way to feel that is through fitness but
you're right there are other ways like
art is a great example but I think art
is the outcome of the others like if I'm
present and I practice and I feel
hardship and pain and I translate that
into an experience and I want other
people to relate that experience I
create art and a lot of the times where
there's effort and time comes art and so
music runs out with your know any
musicians like how they create music is
just a huge mystery but a lot of it has
to do with how their experience has
informed them and a lot of that is
painful experience the tough thing is
like what is the difference between you
know dealing with pain learning to
develop pain tolerance and masochism but
it's a fine line and a lot of the time
especially I think in CrossFit people
cross that line and then they get lost
because they become addicted to the
feelings that tolerating pain come with
that release of endorphins this like you
know community-based a sweat angeling is
what I would call it it's just you know
they're addicted to the outcome and they
forget to get sensitive with the actual
output in Aksarben a tenth one thing
there is it's using a sledge hammer
where a small stone hammer might might
do right you know there's very again
what did I say
you can't hide away from 180 bpm heart
rate no no there's nowhere to go you
know it's happening you feel it you know
this place and it's the same place every
time it's like getting drunk but yeah
you going and drilling
for you guys at me in pounds so like 100
pounds 100 pounds deadlifts tempo
deadlifts like it's not taking you to a
place you're forcing your attention into
the movement you're drilling the
movement you know for people that are
listening that aren't aren't sort of
Fitness II think about anything that you
have to do a lot you know like even
changing a baby you know a spending time
with a baby rocking a baby to sleep you
can choose to do it with all without
presents with or without mindfulness you
can be in that situation fully or you
can be a away and I think people can
take that extreme that top top end real
pushing brushing and that is an easy way
that's this that's the whip right that's
nothing visiting like a whip that is the
whip yeah and I'll grade this on kind of
a curve because there is there stuff
that demands attention at the very top
of intensity and you kind of you decide
you described squirrel suit flying and
some BASE jumping and there was this
there's a documentary called valley
uprising I don't know if you've seen it
it's all it's on Netflix it's a it's one
of the best documentaries I've seen and
it's basically about the culture growth
in Yosemite National Park when climbing
came onto the scene so it starts with
all the great climbers and how they
developed these routes and it kind of
gets to a guy interviews a Dean Potter
and he's a he's dead now and died from I
believe a BASE jumping accident
something related to that but he was an
extreme free solo climber one of the
best and people kind of saw where he was
headed with it and so people attribute
that oh he is just he's just a what do
you call it an adrenaline junkie that
that's that's generally what gets said
about some of these people is that
they're like just seeking a hit like
they're junkies right but how he
described it was how I described
anything that requires presence which
he's trying to touch avoid so he was
specifically talking about a tight wire
rope I like tightrope walking and he'll
walk you know freely up thousands of
feet where any mistake is certain death
like any slip and even like certain
things certain inputs aren't up to you
the wind direction can shift anything
could switch you off and that danger
allows him to be totally present and
appreciative of his life it's actually
the opposite of what most people
attribute to adrenaline junkies which is
I am risking this on this knife edge
because actually it allows me to feel
life at this intensity that I can't get
doing anything else but I back that out
into you know let's call that the sacred
space where everything is so like I
don't know if you've ever been to any
kind of ceremonial happenings but they
create a space and they clean it and it
cleared and everything is precise like
your left ritual right like you know
they smudge and they call in directions
and they do all these you know very
ancient and cultural traditions and the
ideas that they're creating a container
that they can create sacredness inside a
profane world there's a really good book
called the sacred or the profane that
kind of describes how almost all but all
human cultures have this idea of sacred
and profane that in the interesting part
about Fitness is that we've kind of lost
that that's why I'm I kind of go against
the industry so much because we've
created nothing sacred
inside this practice that I think is
really sacred which is intuitively
teaching you about your own psychology
your own physicality your own capability
and eventually your own spirituality but
our gyms have become for lack of a
better term like masturbation pots like
they're just people going to the gym and
looking at themselves and either being
disliked shaming themselves or admiring
themselves in a narcissistic way and
fitness in the industry is purely
aesthetic like we talk about
functionality right like CrossFitters
are talking about all its form and
function and it's functional because I
lift a heavy weight quickly and look how
athletic I am but in reality if you've
ever dealt with CrossFit athletes 99% of
them are dieting before a competition so
that they get more camera time like it
is still the same aesthetic problem
there's very few
maybe at the top where they put
aesthetics aside for performance which
is the expression that we're talking
about but on this sacred profane thing
once I come down to the bottom of the
curve where I think that it's not sacred
snap profane that's actually still
sacred which is mining practice it's
very boring so where I think the most
development comes in is actually some of
the monotony like finding you know
sitting in thinking becomes the most
painful or sitting and not thinking
rather becomes one of the most painful
experiences somebody could have because
their brain is all over the place so in
the fitness world that we're trying to
create we had to kind of start over in
in we constantly start over we
deconstruct what works and then we
recreate what we think is better and so
we're constantly breaking this space
down and rebuilding it into something
that can transform people and one of the
ways one of the simplest ideas that
allowed that to happen is we got rid of
the name for our physical space so there
is no name like we have a brand that we
sell stuff through because we have to
file taxes called nonprofit but the
space is just called the space and one
of the reasons to do that is that way
when people have powerful experiences
here in a container that we've made
sacred they can't talk about it right
it's not a you know hashtag blessed and
hashtag got in my you know whatever I'm
gonna flex show my abs and then say
something inspirational like Gandhi you
know like I don't it's it's become I
guess perverse in a way and what we
wanted to do is rewrite that so this
space is sacred
people can have experiences and they can
talk about the experiences but they
can't talk about the spot that really
illuminated that by not having a name
instead it's a green building warehouse
on night south across from a strip club
and people go what are you talking about
and so no one can find their way here
unless they really seek it out and I
think that was the biggest difference
that we made is that we don't advertise
we don't try to push what we're doing
because if peep
we'll want to find the thing they'll do
some really hard work which means that
takes away you know me having to
convince them that Fitness is an
important thing or convince them that
hard work is important what would you
say to someone that said all that that
is is another marketing ploy that's
triggering off different signals so some
some gyms are super out there they've
got the the guys with the tons and the
white teeth and then other gyms are
we're functional and we've got the
fittest athlete or we've got the biggest
athlete or we put this and someone could
say well that's just another that's just
Michael being another step ahead of the
curve there and thinking well if I make
anti marketing my marketing then the
marketing will work even better because
it sets you apart to some point that is
true there's a guerrilla aspect to this
but I would probably reply like well
then we would probably have more than
seven clients but if it was like a
marketing scheme to get people into this
place but in reality there's seven
people that are basically allowed on a
daily basis to come in and train here
other days we might allow a few other
guests and whatnot to come train on days
that we're training but on
transformational projects when we take
somebody from A to B we limit it it's
very private here and I mean yeah I
would say if the anti marketing was
working we would actually be making
money off of but not we don't instead to
support this entire space we have to
create materials such as books and
things to read and all of these things
in order to support the work that we're
doing that then informs the other
material that we're writing it is a
terrible business model it's we joke
about it often it's like we're really
bad at business okay so I walk into your
space for some somehow I've got on the
guest list
someone's got LEDs got me in VIP or
whatever it is the idea
you know what I mean right the dog the
doorman hasn't stopped me at the door
before he started his shift at the strip
club across the street and I've I've got
in what happens what's it like tell me
about the space is people listening who
will know the the heritage that you guys
have through Jim Jones and all that sort
of stuff like what what you know what
what happens I walk in what's it like
one of the things that we got right at
Jim Jones was having an inside and an
outside in here
stuff happens out there other stuff
happens and so that was the start of
understanding a sacred space and some of
the things that we messed up were
obvious to us but you know we let too
many people in but in reality when
people come in here and they're having
this experience it starts with a lot of
conversations and this this is why sorry
I mean not to use these terms because
it's involved but it's not what we do is
not scalable but there's never gonna be
a day where I'm like cool what we did
worked really well because we know it
works really well
they're only across five sites yeah
exactly
it's like hey let's like duplicate me as
quadruple mean let's just fill up the
space we've got 5,000 square feet let's
open up another one down the street
which is like orange theories or
CrossFit gyms down the street there's no
formula for this so when people come on
in it's really off-putting at first
because for a month I am just asking
questions
that's all I do I ask questions I show
them a couple things I might have them
move around a little bit to get a better
idea I ask them about their work life we
have conversations about their past
their history their traumas their
injuries all of these things and I have
to provide a month people start going
like hey how much is this place because
I haven't charged anything so the first
month I actually do due diligence to see
if I can actually make it work the
reason we're so successful is because I
don't work with people that I don't
think I can win with like we can both
win if it's not a win-win situation I
don't want anything to do with it and it
takes me about a month to assess that
out to understand their home life to
understand their background to
understand
their motivation and then we just start
the process it becomes very one-on-one
but sometimes incorporating groups when
they need it so the idea here that's
different than most gyms is when you go
and do a gym like a CrossFit box they
have a program it's the best program in
the world by the way it's like this
master weightlifter Navy SEAL wrote it
and he's been to the games 19 times in
five years and that program is supposed
to be for everybody because it's the
best in the world it's a super secret
scroll program and if you come to this
gym you get to do that with everybody
that's a super super squirrel and you
know that's intelligent programming look
in there it's written two years in
advance like it's written like you know
a doctorate second your home the next
four years of your life are planned your
back squatting in 2024 on a Tuesday 85%
and instead when people come in I look
at them on the day and decide what they
need to do now that that sounds like
it's a last minute approach what we're
doing is an intuitive approach to a
structure that have broken down so when
somebody comes in after about a month of
analyzing I go back and I work out in
order to get to X on this day they're
gonna need this kind of stimulus it
might be three endurance work during
sessions a week to strength sessions one
body flow session to you know body work
sessions with actually getting recovery
work I try to plan out everything and
then dose it like okay they're if
they're dieting and Aaron is running
their nutrition and cooking for them
then I'm talking to her in order to
slowly break down calorie restriction so
they don't ever feel it or increase
macros in a certain area so that can
handle certain adaptations and then on
the day I have kind of an idea of what
needs to get done you know during the
week I need these three sessions and if
this day they walk in I look in their
eyes and they didn't sleep well well
there goes the high-intensity section
right like that's the last thing I want
to do to somebody is beat them down so
that it's harder to come back our model
now as opposed to what we are doing at
Jim Jones which was to literally just
[ __ ] people up like
that's all we were doing was like really
hard work so people were shocked by all
the work that we were doing and we
became adapted to this heavy workload
and we could tolerate it so that we'd
give it to other people they would break
down and we were just laughs like hot
see you're missing something in your
fitness and that's what most trainers
and coaches do when you come in to see
them they they want to make you hurt to
show them how much you're missing of
their knowledge or their expertise so
it's used that pain I think often gets
used in Fitness as a proxy for secret or
hard work but I mean like I can write a
workout for someone now I'm not a
programmer I've not got my CrossFit
level I can write a program for someone
now that's impossible to do and it's
hard work that doesn't mean that I have
some no super secret squirrel knowledge
right right so a minute on the air down
every five minutes for an hour yeah like
it's like yeah I can make anybody hurt
and that that's a tool but in reality
and if you follow up all bloom and some
of like with Daniel Kahneman and a lot
of these people that are really delving
into the psyche and behavioral patterns
of people we find that pain tolerance
doesn't come from beatdowns it comes
from so slow accumulated ability right
like I tolerated this much I lived cool
it wasn't that bad and then I come back
and I do a little bit more you look at
an elite endurance athlete like somebody
like Rebecca Rush is a perfect example
world champion mountain biker one level
a couple times in a row she's a Red Bull
athlete she's she's known as the queen
of pain like that is her [ __ ]
nickname that's but she doesn't go and
beat herself down every day she actually
goes in and Joy's herself in a natural
environment on a bike being physical in
the way that she loves to express it and
then on the day all this accumulated
tolerance gets put towards one
competition and of course she's gonna
slay everybody she hasn't had to tap
into the Hurt Locker every day in order
to get a mount of all you that's
required for professional stuff perfect
example if I Eliot cacio gay never
never trains above 80% ever fastest man
red planet fastest Monica planner over
26 miles never trained he was 80%
because he's got it in the tank now I
wonder how much of that how much of that
particular physiology has that extra 20%
in there you know like to raise that
ceiling it takes a super super
physiology to have that in the tank we
were talking I was talking to Steve
Fossett from CrossFit GSC the other day
he was talking about how the best
athletes will qualify for a local
competition or whatever it is by only
giving 80% which means they can go back
to training and I was like yes yes but
that's only if you're 80% is good enough
to be as good as everybody else is 100%
or else you have qualified right so and
III think that's a really interesting
point like you know how do we how do
people continue to improve continue to
get themselves better without like you
say just force-feeding themselves with
this pain and and and using pain as a
proxy for hard work so this is where the
boredom and monotony pays off like
there's something structurally it
changes in the brain with enough ordem
and like if you've ever read a book
called the door we have you know Alfred
Lunt out Alex Hutchinson oh and you're
inspire like so Jason yes either yeah
monster waa guy we had him on the
podcast after we read his book mostly
because he wrote he wrote about mark and
then never consulted mark so mark has
the thing is like hey we're gonna have a
conversation and it went well because we
we agree on a lot of the same techniques
in a like a lot of the phenomena that's
behind building great endurance has to
do with the brain and fitness in general
and this is where I said like there's
something in there in his book and we've
noticed it is that if it's not boring
it's not working for endurance but
you're there's this ability and maybe
I'll phrase this on a bigger spectrum
for which we work because we work in
general fitness and capacity GPP general
physical preparedness means that we want
to be capable in each of the desert
needed energy systems as we know them so
we've redefined a lot of them but as
they go strength maybe it's called power
endurance for some people maybe it's
called for us it's capacity
maybe it's metcon whatever it's like
this 90 minute thing and then there's
endurance and then there's ultra
endurance and in between are fettered
with really ridiculous terms like speed
endurance who the hell knows what that
means
and then there's strength endurance was
just another way to rep Mike's called a
three right mind okay I wish it was but
we basically bastardized our terminology
but we do address okay this is the
systems but we chart on top of that one
of the things that I think that were
most well known for is taking stuff like
the physiology and mapping on a
psychological map as well as a
philosophical map on top of that it
might overlays if you imagine you had a
bunch of those forgot what they call
them where they have a projector and
those clear screens or whatever and you
can kind of lay them and they should all
line up and one of the ones that we've
reached psychologically is that each
each thing takes a different temperament
so strength is on a very sympathetic
fight/flight that's the energy system
it's ATP is creatine phosphate
it's this immediate go to the presence
it's self-preservation like if you've
ever lifted anything really heavy when
it's getting shaky leg and you're
starting to do like you know a little
bit of palsy at the top just pass the
mean you're trying to struggle to get
that up your immediate feedback is let
go because you could hurt yourself
self-preservation is an immediate task
for that so ultimately we find with most
athletes that are in that channel
they're very self-involved actually not
not as not to say that as a pejorative
it just means that in order to get good
at their sport they have to be present
inside their self and their self has to
be the existing thing that is most
important but to an extreme point that
sympathetic state becomes narcissism
right all importance and you see it when
when somebody like pulls a super heavy
deadlift and like you know he's thumping
his chest is it not an egomaniacal
it's a very evil presence that that
person is the most he did it he is the
champion and then on the opposite side
we have ultra endurance which runs into
the multi-day then even you can see this
after a couple hours you'll see you know
your chug or like any of these runners
they cross the finish line and they're
in tears they're breaking down they lost
their sense of self and that's because
we find endurance happens in a
parasympathetic state which is loss of
self loss of ego
if you've ever messed with psychedelics
it's ego death which is a deep
parasympathetic state or you can do
breathing drills to get you there
pranayama Breath of Fire all of these
things reinforce a state where I have
lost my sense of stealth I've separated
it from my body and I've become one with
the universe or whatever you want to
describe it as and so as we map these
things we understand that certain states
are good for certain people at certain
times not everybody needs to run into
ultra endurance but if your job is very
self-centered sympathetic you know maybe
you work at a hedge fund where
everything is immediate and your sense
of accomplishment is very personal is
your answer gonna be CrossFit and
powerlifting because you're just like
multiplying the amount that you're in
that state and when you compound that
with your commute to work or the fact
that hey I gotta beat my hedge fund did
you know 6 a.m. to start before
everybody else starts so I wake up to an
alarm at 4:30 I get in my car with
caffeine cortisol is running sympathetic
stays up I'm in traffic I'm swearing at
people I get to the office I'm late I do
all this stuff and then I call it's noon
I got to get my workout in so I run down
to a CrossFit gym I blast an 11-minute
metcon crush you give everybody a
high-five get back to the office finish
work get back in traffic go home and now
I wonder why I feel like I'm diseased
because I can't sleep then and you're
like you're just compounding this state
and in reality like hey maybe we should
you know maybe the especially if that's
working for you by all means so if
you're I don't know a Jocko character
and waking up at 4:30 and crushing the
day is the answer and you feel great you
feel fantastic about your life there's
nothing to change but most people do not
feel good about their life
if most people want change your
transformation they want to become
somebody who they envisioned right I
think the the mapping of whatever you
want to call it the philosophical
psychological with the energy system
that's certainly something you need to I
haven't really heard spoken about before
in James clears atomic habits which I'm
sure you'll be familiar with he talks
about he spoke to one of the Chinese
weightlifting team coaches legendary
Chinese weightlifting team coach and he
said what's a difference between the
athletes who are the best and the ones
who were the very best and he said it's
the ones who can put up with boredom the
most effectively says these people
believe that these top-level athletes
come into the gym and they're just
getting after it Matt Fraser perfect
example almost everyone that's listening
will know who he is fittest man on the
planet like three four times in a row
probably the best cross for athlete to
ever live I'm also gonna guess he
probably ranks in your category of
people who are happy to forego aesthetic
for performance yes this is like the
sort of guy who is dieting down to to
make sure that he's like got an extra ab
or whatever before the CrossFit Games
and um you know you look you look at him
you think yeah yeah he must be getting
after it every day's pumped to get into
the gym like if you if your coach says
hey man it's a recovery day you're just
doing like five by ten minutes on a
rower with a couple of minutes rest and
some breathing exit in a zoo
nasal only breathing at 135 BPM you're
like ain't nobody getting pumped up for
that no no one's getting pumped up from
on a structural work at like a mid not
even getting leaner not even getting
leaner but in fact probably somehow
getting fatter as you do that yeah he is
one of the examples that at point two of
somebody who and you'll see it because
right before the games he adds a couple
pounds like he will gain some fat tissue
but I don't know if it's on purpose but
what it is is he'll be neat like during
the weekend right who are sure hyper
protective and that's what people don't
realize about that that state the other
thing is like of course he like boredom
and that's what Alex Hutchinson talked
about it's like there's something that
develops once you become bored with an
activity how you have to
deal with the pain of it and the
monotony of it and that they they
studied motocross racers and endurance
motorcyclists because if you're racing
for long enough men you're that's a
monotony at a level that most people
don't recognize because the stakes are
still very high but you have to figure
out a way for your brain to not be
simply meditate exactly so I have to be
very present in the moment but also
almost separate myself this comes in
bike racing two events are so long that
eventually I have to separate myself
from my pain and my anxiety about the
future and I just have to be in a
present state and process make sure I
take care of myself and then when the
moment happens when a break happens I
have to be on it and now I'm sympathetic
and I'm seeking I'm hunting it down and
I'm fighting other so these kind of
things are really interesting to us
because a lot of people think that man
training so hardcore and to be honest we
perpetuated that problem when my god is
alright sorry I want to interject that
Michael for someone who doesn't know
what you guys did in the past what is a
what is a two sentence summary of your
training style since buffer before
nonprofit we were responsible for a lot
of the [ __ ] that people know as
movie fitness and we did that for a very
specific reason because it was a really
good platform so we worked with actors
and actresses and stunt crew and crew of
ten movies over the past ten years
physically actually these twelve years
now so 300 300 rise of an empire Man
From UNCLE Manfred's Man of Steel
Justice League Batman vs Superman Wonder
Woman Aquaman aqua man and I can't
remember the others but there was
someone that they all learned at the
same [ __ ] movie
and the reason why we first started
doing it but mark originally did the
original 300 and I came in on on Man of
Steel and then the second 300 as his
assistant
and it was because it was a good
platform to show people that actually
that this is not special that this is
available to everybody
sometimes we won that conversation most
the time we didn't because ego gets in
the way so you take somebody through a
transformation they change and they want
to talk about how hard it was because
they want they want social signaling and
prey yeah
social praise for the work that they've
done everybody wants that everybody
wants acknowledgement of the hard work
that they've done but they make it
harder for people to then do that
themselves
why so the difference well because if if
if you're like hey man how did you get
into such good shape you're strong
you're athletic you're really lean
you're tan
how did you do it and I'm like oh it was
actually really simple I just like
changed how I viewed food and I ate in a
certain manner for a certain amount of
time and I changed how I thought about
training and I started to really be
cured it's gonna be instead of being
obsessed with what I wasn't I started to
be curious about what I was capable of
and I just did that for six months under
the guidance of somebody to make sure I
didn't hurt myself and voila Here I am
that no one's gonna they're gonna go oh
this is just easy for you but instead
they're like you know what I crushed
myself for 27 hours a day for training
sessions and I only ate kale and dust
for six months it was miserable and look
how good ever people are you work so
hard you think that creates a bar like a
seeming barrier to entry that projects a
barrier to entry where people like oh
I'm I'm incapable of achieving that I
therefore it's probably pointless me
even starting I couldn't live on dust
and kale I think so yeah and then the
old tribute to like well he had the best
trainer and the best personal chef and
bodywork people they look at all the
haves because people are really good at
separating the have-nots which is true
it is easier if you have a private chef
no one is gonna argue that but like the
this thing comes up to like oh well
they're getting paid to Train it's like
everybody has the same quit don't quit
conversation in their head when it
is it's an equalizer and it goes beyond
economic status when you start running
all out the conversation is the same it
doesn't matter if you're male female
black white Mexican everybody has the
same voice that goes hey shut this
[ __ ] down this is uncomfortable
it doesn't it's not like hey but you're
rich and you're getting paid so keep
going in fact that's probably the
opposite there I'd like to do this [ __ ]
I don't need this I've got Jerrod but
let's contract it in for two movies at
five mil a pop or whatever it is like I
don't need to [ __ ] put up with this
stuff done deal yeah and why would I
like people already think that I'm great
because everybody around me in my circle
tells me how awesome I am I get Awards
you know on the weekends and I travel
and you know get blown by supermodels so
whatever the thing is it's like yeah it
does but it's actually pretty miserable
because you lack honesty I lack any kind
of presence I want to I want to
interject there because I had Aubree
Marcus on and he first off everyone
that's listening will know what that
episode was like and if you haven't
already heard it I implore you to go
back and listen number 117 one of the
best 60 minutes of conversation I've
ever put out and um he start talking
about one of his fears for actors and he
said that because they're constantly
playing a role he was talking about how
the persona is incapable of receiving
love to capable of receiving praise but
incapable of receiving love because love
is something it's speaking to you
speaking to who you are as a person
right it's about who I see you I see the
values that you have and love is
something that requires honesty when
people are playing a persona which is
literally an actor's job but everybody
that's flowing around to one degree or
another your ego is mediating that Ede
right it's stopping the edge from coming
out and being all visceral and just
meaning that you run across the road and
get hit by car or whatever um and that
that's everyone has this degree of
persona and I think that that's one of
the reasons why you have actors who
seemingly incredibly incredibly
successful how could he be depressed how
could he be this it's because they don't
they feel
for the characters people don't love
Gerard Butler people love king leonidas
they don't love do you know I mean yeah
they are able to transcend that and
actually have suppose this is one good
good advert for the advent of social
media is that now actors are able to
flesh out that personality a little bit
and be more than just you the Maximus
duteous yeah yeah absolutely I think I
would take it one step farther and be
like I wouldn't worry about actors
everybody has a persona like we are all
just characters and I don't know if
you've ever seen an T and me I think
it's called with Jim Carrey when who's
it's a documentary about Jim Carrey
yes very bland he doesn't you off he
doesn't in like it is so profound yeah
and maybe a rude spoiler alert that's
fun in the end when he's talking about
it and he goes I realized at a moment
that I had become Andy and people saw
Andy in me and I realized I didn't know
who I was anymore because I didn't know
who Jim Carrey what Jim Carrey was just
another mask that I needed to try to fit
on and get used to again which is
terrified that that is ego depletion
that's a loss of self loss of identity
it's also in the extreme points known as
schizophrenia and so a lot of these
practices that we do we risk
schizophrenia in order to establish an
identity and that we talk about identity
from this sense because we see with
athletes actors - actors it's a little
bit more obvious but let's say the even
racing bikes since you were 19 and
you're a professional bike racer you've
been in the Tour de France and you
retire at 35 who are you like you've
just lost everything that you were
appreciative for we see in the military
all the time you spend ten million
dollars on an asset to learn the you
know the deadly skills of being an SOF
guy and you go over there you do you
know democratic whatever and you come
back and nobody gives a [ __ ] you need to
work at Starbucks like you're one of the
most expensive educated
people on the planet at killing people
we're doing whatever job is required and
you come back and there is no use for
your skills in society and so you have a
loss there's no acceptance that you need
to figure out a persona and everybody
goes through this is so it's not just
actors
although actors are kind of the obvious
one just because they're pretending to
be somebody else
it's that profession right they are
forced into this persona all the time I
want it on us sitting this point we're
supposed to be talking about fitness but
[ __ ] this is more interesting I was
talking to him took a max you know took
a maxes yeah it's you actually yeah have
you seen his new stuff I have not I read
I hope they serve okay and then I
followed Ryan holidays path of help
marketing that thing so yes so he's this
old frat I a party boy that publicized
all of his stuff and I had him on had
him on the show a couple of weeks ago
and man like he's he's just gone
complete
he's rebounded off the other side he's
completely internalized done so much
self worked so much self inquiry
incredibly incredibly self-aware like
one of them are self-aware people I've
ever ever seen if you want to find out a
little bit more about him he's got a
newsletter which is lessons I've learned
with that he's tweeting every day and
then at the end of the week he'll just
send you a summary of all of the lessons
he's learned and almost all of them are
reflections on himself and this that any
other what I was talking about was
people now see him as this guy that
created a literary genre right frat ire
he was this guy he was party guy [ __ ]
girls going around doing the thing
getting drunk throwing up on people you
know just doing the thing this is took a
max I put took a max in the took a
maxbox this is who he is now and then he
goes away and people still see him as
that right people still seem as that he
then comes back having done some work
and people are like no no we don't want
that tokamaks in fact before this
podcast today right I went on and
someone replied to one of his tweets he
did a lesson I've learned real good one
again a Karen Moore what it was it was
right currently what it was and someone
replied and said man I miss your old
stuff and he just replied and he said
want the old me by my old books and the
point is we have these different epochs
in our life right we have this is who
Michael was when he was doing Jim Jones
this is who Michael is now he's doing
when he was doing nonprofit in the
initial stages now this is what he moves
into now and people don't like that
people really really get triggered as
they watch people ascend and transcend
and become something different from what
they were because I think that growth
mindset and the ability for people to no
longer be what they were and be
something else identifies in some people
that are watching holy [ __ ]
like that person continues to move while
I'm in inertia like I'm stagnating and
this really hurts to watch someone pull
away from me so we talked about this in
transformation process and there's
there's a lot to talk worked up
we kind of unweave out of this process
but it starts with like generally when
somebody wants to make a change and they
come to us so like all I want to lose X
amount of weight and I think that that's
the thing and my first question is how
fat is your spouse right like how how
does no how does that question go down
usually it's shocking which is also to
watch somebody squirm is also good like
how do you just because I know already
like it's very rare that one person is
in really good shape and the other
person has just let themself go there's
a reason for that but the reason I ask
is because if somebody starts to change
and transform the person who's looking
at them closely will see it's a
reflection of their non progression and
they will try to bring them down so you
see this in office right somebody starts
dieting and in the lunch room
it's [ __ ] Karen's birthday so there's
like 12 cakes I'm like it's Karen's
birthday it only happens once a year
it's like once in a lifetime have a
piece of cake going no I'm good I'm
having a salad and you're like everybody
will try to get that [ __ ] to eat
a piece of cake because it's a reflect
of their non-compliance and the The
Closer that person is the more sabotage
they will cause so when I tell people
how fat is your spouse or ask them and
they tell me a little bit over wintered
okay realize that when I require 10
hours to sleep and you sleep in past
them and I require all these things and
you start to change they're gonna start
making you brownies they're gonna be
telling you hey look how good you've
done let's go out for a treat you
deserve a reward because they want to
actually stop looking at themselves and
I think that happens because I think
human beings are reflectors we are
mirrors but our mimetic beings I think
as Paul Graham says in fact in Peter
Thiel's job application he asks people
what is the belief that you hold which
disagrees with 99 percent of the people
that you know why are you breaking where
are you breaking the program where are
you deprogramming yourself I maybe will
get a little bit out there right now but
I've had you know this has really helped
shift my thinking I am atheist and I
don't think that's a choice I think you
know at best agnostic being and worrying
and you Tom being an atheist must feel
like a little bit of a tough place for
it to be true but I don't think there's
I think it's just a natural inclination
to how you look at the universe and I
say atheistic is and I don't believe in
a personal creator I don't connect with
anything like that but I do not deny
creation as a process and when I look at
human beings being here on earth as a
product of the sun's energy and the
Earth's ability to nurture growth and
life I know yeah we were created and
perhaps our only job is to be a
reflection of the universe so if I
contend that the universe is making
everything which I don't think you can
argue that I think that the universe's
art is our brain so the universe won't
you know because it's a creation process
why not create something that can
actually appreciate you that is the
ultimate creation but that that's your
that's your hope for having a son or a
daughter that's your hope for creating a
business is that the appreciation is a
election of your own creation so I
figure human beings are a reflection in
the fact that if ever you're not looking
up at the stars going what the [ __ ] this
is this is amazing I'm so appreciative
for my experience here you're a broken
tool you're up you're a hammer without a
handle and I think a lot of depressive
states are a multifactorial but a big
part of that is not being like not
seeing the utility at being a creator
yourself mon-sol daniel SHM actin burger
have you ever heard of it I have no
civilization emerging so he is coming on
the podcast this week I'll link you to
some of his stuff I'll link you to
everything I've sparked on you over this
he has a talk which is about emergence
and it is the hardest-hitting 20 minutes
that I've ever listened to in my life
it's unbelievable the synopsis of it is
that we talk about entropy being the
kind of the Routledge force that just
continues to pummel everything right
that you have increasing amounts of
randomness occurring as you go along
it's also supposed to be the reason for
why heat occurs and a bunch of other
things sure
but you talked about the fact that the
uniqueness that we have is that we're a
conscious agent who is not only a
passenger on the ship but more so a
pilot able to affect the ship's
direction and like when you fully fully
internalize this conversation on
emergence which will be linked in the
show notes below you'll have to listen
to it probably like three or four times
to get it at least I did it's not a
listen to it on to time speed thing like
prayer and when I fully internalized
that I was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like
it's it's it's right it is correct and
you right with what you say as well this
connection to what is going on this
grander self-transcending who we are all
that sort of stuff
it sounds so esoteric right but there's
something to it there has to be
something to it because of the way that
it makes people feel and I think you
know through whatever your chosen mode
whether it be strong psychedelic drugs
whether it be looking up at the sky
whether it be sitting in silence in a
quiet room in a float tank whether it be
getting your heart rate to 180 BPM
whether it be you know whatever it might
is singing on stage performing the most
intricate routine that you can in
martial arts form or you know pink pick
you're like what are we trying to do
what are all of those things what they
all got in common they definitely put
you in a state I I connected it kind of
connected to myself because I went
through obviously change and I think
it's important to recognize what that is
obviously I don't you probably read a
lot of Joseph Campbell's stops the arc
of the hero to hear what the Thousand
Faces and I think we we forget that
we're all kind of on that path at all
times and then if ever we are not on
that path we're risking demise like if
we're not ever trying to change into the
thing that we hope to become then we're
risking just a violation of the spirit
or whatever you want to call it and a
lot of people don't see this they just
go oh you know I want I want a new body
or I want to be fit for once and they
don't realize that actually what they're
they're talking about is becoming a
different person what Donna Mae so I
mean if you're familiar with
psychedelics you'll know what the hero's
doses but a lot of people have a
misconception of what the hero's dose is
they think it's because it's so scary
that you have the courage to take it and
really what it is is it's so terrifying
but the scary part is it will change you
so a hero is a hero not because he has
courage to go into it because he has the
courage to come back and change like he
goes and finds the elixir and he brings
it back a different person to help
inform whoever or however you want to
contextualise that so that's how we
that's kind of how I met you know my own
transformation it's like if ever I'm not
willing to change I'm not doing
something right but I I think one
constant that has really helped is like
this map of the universe looking back
I'm a reflector yeah gratitude
journaling all that [ __ ] but in reality
when I look at it I'm just dumbfounded
by how little energy we can actually put
out like our output is so minuscule
compared to our
creator our son and I don't know if
you've ever looked at it maybe I'll send
you a link to this NASA has if you get
out there enough you can actually hear
the Sun some mix and noise and it's a
rhythm it almost sounds like a binaural
beat it just and every once in a while
twice a week about I'll sit down and
listen to that because it reminds me how
[ __ ] pathetic I and the reason why is
because if I want to do a good job about
reflecting my environment it means I do
what what created me what what gave me
life what gives me nourishment which I
look at is the Sun and so I do workout
for 15 minutes and I follow the ground
and sweat I'm like ah that's the hardest
thing ever I'm gonna rest for like seven
days or whatever the Sun has been up
there for billions of years just putting
energy into all of this
and so whenever I feel like I'm tired
I always listen to that video and I get
up and I go put energy into my space
because really if I create an
environment which is what this building
is and I put enough energy into it other
people will come in and they will feel
that energy and they will grow they will
change and then I just create change
ever change ever change and it helps me
figure again how pathetic it is but how
I could be appreciative of the process
that gave me me is I can put energy and
help people give them them does that
make sense oh no no not at all one of
the things that I've been thinking about
a lot recently is how we can kind of
transcend our suffering right like what
we we have things that happen to us bad
things will happen the people that we
love will die literally the only thing
that we all know is that one day all of
this will be gone to the subject of the
poet Rilke II and I think it's Freud
walking through a garden it's a short
essay called on transience real key
looks like he's gonna cry and he turns
to him and says like what's wrong and he
says I just I can't believe the fact
that one day all of this is going to be
gone isn't it such a tragedy that all of
this is going to be gone and that one
day you'll be dead and I'll be dead and
all of this will literally decay into
needed no heat death but it's
you know that that's the long long long
story of that and it is you know it is
it is a tragedy to have that but as we
go through our life and as bad things
happen to us a good example for me that
I've been reflecting on recently is I've
been injured so I've had two bulging
discs l3 and s1 which is meant I haven't
basically been able to do fitness Who am
I without my fitness that's a question
of you know 18 months 18 months of being
the the kid with the water wings on in
the corner of the room like doing
another round of side plank and
bird-dogging you know like core
stiffening I want to go see dr. Stu
McGill in Canada fluo yeah
Canada's to go and see him he's a beast
and you know I did I did this stuff and
I'm thinking [ __ ] like this sucks this
sucks this sucks
and I wouldn't recommend it to anybody
as a personal development strategy like
it's sure it's suck dick but first thing
you taught me was who i'ma without my
fitness and the second thing that it
taught me was reflecting on that means
that I can now tell the people that I
listen to this podcast and the people
that I know look if something happens to
you where you get something that you
thought was so caught or being you know
something had done for 13 years that was
I'm the fitness guy I'm the guide it's
in shape not only is my routine around
that my personality's around that
wrapped around that blah blah blah like
Who am I without my fitness but now I
can say to the people that are listening
look like it will be okay it's going to
be fine because your desire for growth
in your desire for progression will
naturally like a vacuum it'll suck or
the stuff into it and then when you get
whatever you've just lost back when you
develop it and you now have conscious
competence of that particular thing
you're so much more appreciative of it
like today I went in class class was a
million things that I'm not supposed to
do from dr. McGill so I couldn't do any
of them so I had like a poly bar I was
doing like snatch pulls with a poly bar
in class and those guys that flinging 80
kilos around and blah blah and I'm like
[ __ ] like I'm doing it like I get to do
fitness this is fitness
like I know that it's like the most
nerfed child version of fitness that
anyone's ever seen but I got to do it
and I was like [ __ ] like imagine what
its gonna be like when I can pick up two
hundred two hundred kilos again you know
yeah and that being able to transcend
the
suffering the eve heart by telling other
people by using the experience that
you've had to then teach other people
how they can expedite transcending that
same suffering or an analogous suffering
or whatever it might be is the ultimate
middle finger to anything bad that ever
happened to you had an experience with
depression had an experience with a
family member dying had an experience
where something that you cared about got
taken away from you if you take that
learning distill it down into something
really valuable and then teach it to
someone else so that it makes their life
better that is you just going [ __ ] you
like you thought that you had me not
only have you not got me but you don't
have this person either that's I mean
falls in line with I think stuart mcgill
color that that like the gift of entry
and that's a lot of it it's writing card
yes yeah it could it could be and this
comes back to the depression topic it's
really rare that you meet somebody that
is very well-off financially and
whatever whatever we want to conclude
that success is for that person and that
they don't have symptoms of depression
in fact suicide is more rampant in those
middle ranges of successful incomes
middle high range than in any other
demographic and you have to wonder at
what point why does that happen and a
lot of it has to do with bad that in
this again you don't want to wish that
this my my argument with sam Harris on
philosophy the point is to reduce
suffering and I go man you really reduce
people's ability to know themselves and
so although you don't wish it on anybody
and some suffering men you really want
you want to have compassion and empathy
and stop it for that person but really
what you're stopping is their own
development i suffering is gonna happen
and if it doesn't how good would it be
and again this is like it comes back to
my problem with the idea that the soul
is infinite or that we are going to live
forever and a happy ever and everything
is happening is that everything is just
so good well Deena what like five days
of nothing but the best everything makes
you not appreciate the best of
everything
so it becomes it becomes nothing so if
you have all good experiences all the
time you have no experiences all the
time because you have nothing to compare
that to
we need polarity in order to understand
the universe you need up and down light
and dark you meet all these concepts
this is this is philosophically sound
where you won't appreciate anything
unless you have its opposite so it's
tough to say you know man I I do want to
teach me if I think as Peter Thiel like
he's quotas like any idiot can learn
from their own experiences it takes a
truly intelligent person to learn from
others yeah which is true but also
there's some visceral things that you
just have to learn on your own and I
think being injured is one of those I
went as bike racing back in the day I
fell in a Time Trial and shattered my
elbow like twenty-seven fragments it was
close to an amputee if I would tore one
more ligament that would have just
amputated it but they did this weird
surgery to get it back and I'm a fairly
physical person and their first thing
was like well that's over with mm-hmm
like you're not gonna do that anymore
and it was almost like oh like what like
what how do you even go about it but the
lessons are a you are what you do like
you your activities are not you they're
just something that you process and I
think it's also true to recognize that
you are not a noun you are not a thing
like you are not we say person place or
thing that's it now that's not true
that's that's a that's to help grammar
work correctly its sentence structure
but it is not true you are not a thing
you don't just exist nothing as a thing
it's all process all of this is just
process everything is just moving all
the time and this is actually the segue
into how we got back into the fitness
space because we obviously speak
esoterically very easily because of
these mortals that are podcast about
different topics cultural affairs all of
these things and we have really denied
the request to add anything to fitness
until this year in fact our symposium is
called fit
[ __ ] so it gives you an idea yeah sorry
to check that are you only doing that in
the UK are you doing it in the US as
well uh we're doing so we mostly just do
the symposiums in the u.s. the one that
we had planned for the UK we actually
just had to cancel because of the
[ __ ] corona scare it's just no yes
well it's Hertz on two parts because I
know it's ridiculous but it hurts on
another part is because I am now because
I cancelled it I feel like I added into
the panic even though it's just it
wasn't possible for us right like it was
just like look people aren't travelling
to do this stuff so if we can't fill out
a seminar we can't come there it just
doesn't look like it was moving so we
just postponed it hopefully after we'll
come back because at UK we have quite a
large audience in the UK channel area
yeah plus a good one he's largely
responsible to that so he comes start
symposiums here that's how Elodie got
involved she came out to symposium last
fall and those symposiums although we
call them fitness or [ __ ] people
realized really quickly that we're not
talking about fitness unless we're
talking about the industry when you come
to the symposium its structured that the
first day is dialogue and we don't have
this has changed in the past year we do
not have material to teach which is very
terrifying for us at heart at the very
start because most people they teach a
seminar heycome learning these points
that I've dictated that you should know
and what dawned on me last year was that
I don't want to teach like that I want
to know what people want to know that we
can do and then we'll go down that but
to get to that point we just have to ask
questions because people don't know what
they want to know and so it starts for
the first three hours we're just
bouncing questions off of people you
know why are you here
what are you doing what do you want to
know what's worth knowing what's what is
it to understand something we go down
these really deep concentrated things
and eventually we end up at a very
similar place each time but then people
will understand our thinking when you
come to subject so the next day when
we're actually talking about fitness and
how to progress it and you know how how
to set somebody up to learn about
themselves they have this you know
12-hour conversation to back bonus to
lucky next right yeah exactly so as
opposed to run at this heart rate for
this long that's just an abstraction
that's just an easy way for me to get
out of responsibility of actually
teaching somebody but if I actually
teach somebody I'm teaching them to be
sensitive and to pay attention to their
personal organism which is what does it
feel like right now can you talk to me
during this effort like heart rate is a
part of it is that above this so what
happens if you know and this is a really
cool experiment you can do with people
we're doing steady state stuff so I want
you to stay around 70 percent max heart
rate then we're gonna try to express
efficiency and whatever modality you
want to get good at running biking etc
or whatever let's take biking so okay
you're spinning you're at one forty four
forty five minutes everything is fine I
come over I chat with you I take my half
glass of whatever I'm drinking and I set
it on the edge of a box next to you and
it's half way on the edge so it looks
like it's about to fall immediately that
person's heart rate will ask but that
responds to the same stimulus will
escalate because their brain has just
taken on another task it needs to stop
that glass from falling and so what we
do is try to teach people in that space
all of these things personally right if
you're just running every day that's
fine that works you get pretty fit but
if you're running thinking about work
and all your other responsibilities
you're not actually trying to get
efficient at something so we teach
people to clear their thought process to
create a sacred space in which they can
become good at something and then we
enter a distraction so it's like an
advanced meditative process right we
bring in distractions come back to the
breath come back to the breathing come
back to the focus think of Duffing if
something comes up that's okay
acknowledge it but don't worry about it
the glass is not in your control physics
will take care of it and if it breaks
your effort still needs to be done so
something goes wrong you need to keep
doing you need to keep going you need an
art you know definition of endurance is
you need to see something through to the
end the same thing is true with strength
strength this is we recently came out
with our strength manual and basically
people asked for a long time hey will
you write some programming
used to do when most of us wonder the
mica for the love of God can you just
teach us some fitness for one thing
yeah just quit talking about physics and
dumb [ __ ] yeah well I thought about it
and I thought you know what I could do
because what happens is I say no we
don't teach fitness I'm not gonna write
a program what happens is people just go
to the next shitty program right and
then they're like trying to take our
concepts and apply them to some other
thing which they don't know it well
enough to be able to do that I can do
that I'd go do the small dog program and
and understand our take on it and
understand what I'm working and
therefore the small of program is great
the hash squat program is great all of
these things work if you have a
foundation of understanding of what's
trying to be accomplished so my idea is
a guy'll bust-up program I'll explain
our methods yeah don't be done with it
six weeks would be awesome what does
sell the [ __ ] out of it and what
happened to sneaking and start working
on it bouncing back and forth and I
realized we were [ __ ] in way over our
heads so a six week project became an
eight month project and even then I was
still not happy with that I was sitting
on it and then I kind of had some
epiphanies and it clarified everything
it's because we redefine strengths and
this is what we do and this is we write
things not because we want to teach
people but because we want to understand
better ourselves like I write articles
and ideas not because I'm on a soapbox
per team what hey you should do what I
do it's really putting words to paper
and articulating them
help me understand them better so every
piece that I write understand that I
learned something by writing it that I
didn't know before I started writing it
and this was no different although my
ego was keeping me from learning that
lesson as I go you already know
everything about that you can express
straight perfectly you can get people
strong and I didn't know how I did it
until I read to find it so we created
the strength program yes it's based off
of just moving the lifts the squad in
whatever variation want a deadlift and
oppressive sorts classic powerlifting
although we do recommend a horizontal as
opposed to a press overhead as opposed
to a bench press although both programs
work so there is like numbers and things
that you should do
and it's a you know an eight week
program and testing it both end so it is
literally everything that we hate done
in a way that you can appreciate it
which is to start with a definition
which I think is incorrect in most
physiological terms most people come to
strength they see somebody back squat
right heavy weight [ __ ] thousand pounds
that guy is so strong it's like yeah he
is but why is he strong is it because
he's moving the weight say no because
movement is power but we refer to things
that move is powerful a wave when it
hits you in the face is powerful because
it's moving a castle is it strong or a
fortress isn't strong because it's
moving it's strong because it's holding
so when we strength train we're
practicing holding the spine in a very
specific position or a joint or whatever
in gymnastic that might be the shoulder
girdle or whatever neutral extended arch
spine all of these things are an
expression of the ability to contract
and hold the position and I think when
we abstract and we use a barbell to get
strong we forget that we're actually
trying to hold our spine in a specific
position and so we forget to express it
correctly and so we went back and kind
of reiterated why we hold things
why isometric contraction is so
important why gymnastics is probably the
greatest expression of strength and I
know that'll make a lot of people mad
they're like really the back squats the
king of exercises although has like 90%
of it it's not applicable to 99% of the
sports so the just I'm gonna get on up
like my oil thinking people will forgive
me for my decorating the squat but in
reality it can teach you some things
abstractly but lifting weight is a level
removed from contracting and holding the
body and this is the hardest thing to
teach is like the dog is not the dog
right the if I write the word dog down
it's not a dog itself and that's how
we've created strength we've said a
400-pound back squat is strong but
that's a arbitrary abstraction for the
expression of holding and so instead
what we try to do is
remember that if I need to push against
something it means I'm not developed
correctly because I can't control the
contraction in my own body once I can
contract to a hundred percent or
whatever your marker is for the
expression of strength it means I have
control over my body I have the will to
make it contracted the way and hold
against the things that I want to hold
against whether that's in an MMA fight
if somebody puts me up against the cage
and I need to hold my position or it's
holding my spine in a deadlift whatever
whatever the thing is whole strength is
a foundation for the expression of power
and so power comes only after I can hold
my position in my stabilization in order
to express power but people go about it
differently I went about it by
expressing power first because I'm
fairly good at snatching and clean and
jerking and that fell better for my ego
but I'll always use a looser clean on
the squat because I'm not strong my
spine is unable to hold position that's
necessary to stand it up so in learning
this ourselves we were able to now apply
it to other people our strength training
looks mildly different than it did ten
years ago and that's not because the
stuff that we're doing before was wrong
we were just insensitive to what needed
to be focused on it's um it's
interesting to hear you talk about
training plans that are more
prescriptive it's you know what everyone
that's listening is hearing you in the
throes of I want to elucidate about
these ideas and the philosophy that is
behind this but I also appreciate that
at some point like the tip of the spear
got to enter the gym and in the gym you
need to know what you need to do it's
all well and good walking in the gym and
saying that I'm transcending the ego and
I'm gonna be present in the breath like
you need to know you need to know what
what weight to put on the barbell or
what percentage you're lifting today
right
I wonder how challenging you've found it
and I don't I haven't spent much of time
listening to mark talk but I imagine it
must be similar for him as well like
when um when you guys get into one of
your symposiums or you get this and you
have to actually go right now is the
time for people to get a
X piece of machinery out or X piece of
like kit out there has to come a point
where you're right enough with the like
erudite verbose tough time for me to yes
lift lift some things do you almost you
almost resent that a little bit or do
you still kind of have a love for the
for the that side of no I I think it's
philosophy applied like is how I look at
it it's like yeah we do all this hard
thinking work but eventually thinking
gets in the way of moving and what I
really want is to move I want to feel
things there's this really great quote
of like there's thinking believing I
can't remember the other one but then
there's feeling and feeling is the rotor
damaged so this is this is a but mr.
fuller thing it like it really is useful
in the fact that I know I can find it
maybe I can't find it out here this
whatever you think or believe or no
you're a lot of other people because
you're you're sensing their ideas you're
just you're reiterating another person's
thought or belief but the moment yeah
but the the moment you feel you're
nobody but yourself
and so yes take our ideas and try to
understand them and comprehend them but
unless you translate that into you
feeling it does nobody any good
and so the symposiums although they're
highly emotionally charged and we make
it that way on purpose I mean a lot of
people think they're gonna come here
we're talking about how hardcore we hate
humanity and how you know how people are
disappointing all those things are true
but when we come here what we've done is
circled the wagons right we've we are in
harsh territory we live in a culture
where not a lot of people feel like they
belong they're not connecting to a lot
of people I live next to 20,000 people
and I don't know any of my neighbors
like I know none of them I have to come
down to a building 30 miles away to say
hello to somebody looks familiar that is
unprecedented in human civilization so
when I say circle the wagons it's like
we're in an area that's hostile and we
need to ban too
together and talk about ideas and
concepts and values that we can all give
behind and that takes getting down to
the truth of it like what is true what
does it mean for something to be true
all these ideas understand that there is
no such thing as truth there's just you
know a fixed point somewhere that is
changing and this is this is where it
gets really weird as we talk about
strength about holding nothing is
holding there's no such thing as
stillness stillness doesn't exist in the
universe it is all waving it is all
particles cells are always mutating and
dying and creating and life doesn't move
so you should you should you know embody
that keep moving but embody all the
things that you need to move in the
direction that you want to go so the
symposium to talk about this esoteric
stuff and then when we get down to it
now let me show you how to feel this and
this is the this is my problem with like
a remote coaching situation it's like no
I might show somebody how to do a hollow
or I can explain kind of how to do a
wheel or arch the wheel or you know all
these weird body flow things that we've
done as of late the crane dance or
whatever but until you're here in the
room and you see me do it and you go I
see you do and I go no no your spine is
like this in your legs like this and
your knee isn't you know your ear you're
not activating it you're not active
spine active being active hip and then
you feel it and you contract so hard
that you cramp up and you fall over now
you know what it feels like so you can
go practice properly so the symposiums
become a really important part not only
for the conversation to feel all the
fields as it were which sometimes can be
jarring but also to feel your body and
what it is to actually do something
correctly for the first time how many
people do you think that here this is
the team that was behind Jason Momoa and
Henry Cavill and 300 this is the team
that's behind that and then someone
hasn't done their due diligence and like
yeah I'm gonna go train with Michael
Evans I'm gonna go and get after and
he's gonna tell me about like whether
push pull legs is actually better than a
five-day split and then they sit down
and you just force-feed them this red
pill about reality over the course of 12
hours while Paul warriors cowls from the
back corner of
I guess it could be shocking but really
and we get this often like you know what
was Henry Cavill training program like
how did he get so big and muscular and
strong and in all honesty is like there
was no program there was a lot of
conversations that happen every single
day like we we sat down and we did the
same thing we're all talk about a
concept or idea it elicits a response
that look into training and then we'll
talk about that training after why was
it hard what was the conversation like
you know why did why did you feel like
he wanted to quit after ten minutes when
we had 30 minutes to go like what do you
think you didn't sleep enough like we
just asked questions and that that
throws people off because people love
definitive answers and if you love
definitive answers you're not going to
like me so I don't have any I just got
this if people have got this far in the
podcast expecting definitive answers
from you my card don't think that
they've been listening
answer is 5x5 bench on Monday even our
strength program when trying to like
move people like I was really hesitant
to put anything specific in there
although we need to people need to know
what to do on Monday and Wednesday or
whatever and so we broke it down into
who are you like try to ask questions
like where you at we have three
categories newbie novice and expert
that's not saying that newbie is easy an
expert is advanced and you should do the
super secret scroll program it shows
that designation is different an expert
in powerlifting is going to do a
powerlifting meet therefore the
structure for which he builds strength
is hyper specific a newbie is learning
strength and the destination is really
specific
so you decide kind of designate where
you're at and then you go down that path
you can always advance the path and
become a novice and become an expert
that doesn't mean you're suddenly strong
it means that your destination has
changed and this is how we appropriate
the destination so explaining that to
people as opposed to Henry did this work
out of that work guy did the 300 workout
and then he squat five days a week
it was and that's how you do it and then
you eat chicken and broccoli you know
cool thanks people wouldn't people like
that because people don't really like
questions in general towards who they
are as people and this is like we write
this in the beginning of the spring it's
really easy to say hey what's your spot
do I squat 4:05 cool I think I know who
you are as opposed to how do you
overcome burdens like that that question
to most people will start bringing tears
because they stop thinking about a
[ __ ] weight and they start thinking
about how they dealt with their mob died
from cancer they start dealing with the
trauma of abuse when they were a child
how did you overcome that it's like
strength when it comes to the
psychological is how do you hold your
ideals how do you hold who you are your
character as a person through the
roughest of sort when you're poor and
you're eating ramen and you have no
money and there's no exit how they do
not do the easy thing how do you not go
into prostitution not that anybody would
hire me but like how do you not go into
these traps how do you not turn towards
drugs that are escapism not the other
kind of drugs which are awesome but
there's these traps in life and we need
to know how to be strong psychologically
so they don't fall into them and I think
the more direct we are with our
questioning as opposed to abstract 405's
abstract how do you how do you overcome
burden that that's a direct question and
the more you get a direct question the
more connection you have to human beings
because now we're being honest with each
other
hmm something that I've been thinking
about throughout this conversation is
the tokamaks
epochs of life thing and it's
interesting to see with you guys as well
you kind of have these little cycles of
this was us and then this was us and
then this was us and now this is us and
this is me and then I'm thinking about
what's next and I'm gonna try and make a
prediction about what I think is is next
for you guys and it actually comes from
Derek Siver's you know Derek Siver's is
yeah so he's on he's on the podcast
tomorrow I have no idea how the [ __ ]
same as you he's he's probably second to
you in terms of who's the most
challenging to try and get on the
[ __ ] podcast he's got this really
interesting thing right he talked about
directives
so he's read hundreds of probably
thousands of books and what he did was
he realized that a book what most of a
book is is convincing you of the
author's authority on this subject yeah
the vast majority of it is a combination
of context which is examples and you
should trust what I say but like Matthew
Walker why we sleep it is an entire book
an entire book that says sleep out as
sleep eight hours a night but it's there
it's [ __ ] 250 300 pages long
right that's what that's what it is
right so you need I am an authority you
should trust me this is why by in my and
by and believe me bla bla bla
um but and Derek said this and he
[ __ ] read pilled me on it while
researching him for this podcast he said
it on Tim Ferriss Anam he says the
bottom line is if you trust someone
sufficiently you trust the authority
figure which is giving me instructions
sufficiently all you need is the
directive this all that you need is the
directive because you don't need the
context you don't need the examples you
don't need to trust me trust me thing
it's just what do I do
so I think that within the next I'd put
a hundred quid on it I wouldn't put much
on it
my possibly quid I'd put hundred foot on
the fact that you guys loop back around
from being in a more super hardcore real
kind of outward showing type of fitness
which was still kind of ante marketing
and like kind of guerrilla and motive
against the grain into this more erudite
kind of a boss there is no form system
and I think that those two were then
gonna coalesce at some point in the
future and that you're going to have a
not a minimum effective dose but like
the concentrated the uranium 505 [ __ ]
version you know like the hyper dense
neutron star [ __ ] I think I think that
might happen I genuinely think that your
your your guys's progression may come
full circle and you'll actually get back
into into directives in a very kind of
pure and condensed way
it's possible I mean we've removed
ourselves from the movie industry
because we didn't feel look we don't
feel that repetition at that level was
helpful anymore and what it was taking
away from was a creative process of like
reinventing ourselves because in reality
you're just like the same okay you need
to lose how much way how do you want to
look shirtless how do you like what kind
of food do you like to eat what kind of
exercise hurt you like it's the same
questions over and over again and so
there's no personal evolution we dropped
it with a thought that we've mastered it
it's not what everyone we're but you
know it's not that we're closed to the
idea it's a we turned them down because
nothing has sunk in but the second
something piques our interest we go
there and I know that we're very like
squirrel like there's no there's no plan
here we write down ideas we have good
conversations and when something opens
up like this sounds really ridiculous
but we're working on a tarot card game
right now okay
it's me I'll explain it later when it's
more well developed the bank video maybe
I'll send you it once I printed off but
though the idea is that we should not be
held back by anything that we've made a
judgment about in the past that's really
hard to do I've made a judgment about
CrossFit I made a judgment about certain
competitions about what is a dream
exactly and I've made all these
judgments it I shouldn't I shouldn't do
that I should leave everything open to
interpretation and not go in like an
idiot like I've never been anywhere
before but to address something as is
this the same thing this is retin-a my
recognizing the same human errors in the
end people ruin everything but I should
appreciate that some people make it
better and I should be open to that fact
there's some people who make it better
that our symposiums have illuminated
that to me that there is like a spark
and a hope to the people that come here
for whatever reason people heard me and
Mark ranting on the internet on a
podcast it's somehow they flew and now
they want to spend time with us and
there's some of the most genuinely
beautiful people that have never met
their their stories that they share
Riaan form how
do and how we practice and that that's
shopping I don't know I don't know where
it's going so I also don't like to
predict because I don't want to contain
myself I've got 100 pounds on the line
I'm fine with that I'll let you bet as
much as I I like the space that we have
like I've really like I said that the
other day kind of over the internet
because we had a conversation talked
about developing the next endurance
manual and we just had a mind-blowing
conversation about not endurance like it
was yeah that doesn't know we were
talking about the endurance man you
didn't use the word endurance once well
and I'll share this story if you have
time for it
is it so I I frequently he practice with
ayahuasca like us
that's a plant that speaks to me in a
way that it helps creativity there's all
these other things to go along with it
but I have transformed myself using it
as Allah has taught me how to be
somebody that I didn't think was
possible but when using it it is not all
rainbows and trippy you know passes
through the constellations or whatever
your experience is with it some of them
are very hard and your intentions are
really important we've been trying to
practice frequently as of recent because
it's harder it's not if you do it every
once in a while it's kind of like a
yahoo and it's whatever for whatever
reason it's communicated to the idea
that I need to sit with it frequently to
get good at understanding how things
work and so I've agreed to it and
although it's hard and I most the time I
want to hit the eject button last
weekend
I've been riding the endurance manual
and I've been having a hard time with it
and Mark being mark was are you gonna
think about endurance this weekend when
you said [ __ ] you muck no because that's
just asking for suffering like you if
your intention is to learn about
endurance you're [ __ ]
like you're gonna hurt really bad and I
have to be really careful with what my
intentions are when I say it with
world's most powerful psychedelic drug
because if I ask for learning right like
I want to learn something really
specific the best way that I learned is
by burning my [ __ ] hand and that is
not fun so I also have to be careful
with like hey this time I just want to
enjoy myself well guess what I enjoy
suffering it can always go south but
this this time I was like no I'm not
gonna think about turns I just I'm not
been hit I've been traveling Australia
competing I'm exhausted I haven't ever
stopped for months and I have to go
right into we basically landed and went
right into a ceremony in cells like I'm
jet-lagged all this other stuff comes up
so I'm just gonna think about love or
something cuz [ __ ] whatever like him to
[ __ ] and so I immediately took the first
dose of in you know she got bad we
didn't really the Alex Hutchinson's face
just flow not that bad in fact it wasn't
that if you listening you've got a
beautiful face no sorry about that one
it is I wish it was that direct but the
lessons in these kinds of experiences
are so complex that you really have no
idea what you're gonna get and so I said
love or something and there's another
process for you like you know make an
offer and receipt her in ceremony when
you think about something and my wife's
my mother-in-law my wife's mom she's
been battling cancer for quite some time
and it looks like it's getting the
better or for the past couple months or
breast cancer has turned into brain
cancer and it's kind of developed her
entire brain she's losing a lot of
function so I thought about her and I
was like I've been offering and go up
there and come back and I bumped my
chest i I've had this like weird pain in
my chest for like a month and it's a god
that's for sure cancer I'm for sure died
I literally am gonna die like in a
couple weeks and no one gives a [ __ ]
about me I've done nothing to effect
change in the world like I thought I
would and I'm just a miserable piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] all these people like so much
for the love intention here we go yeah
yeah and then I and then it dawned on me
that this is what Aaron's mom spent go
through
more than 10 years and how nobody is
here for her and how I'm not there for
her right now and it was just like
sobbing for an hour just like thinking
about what a miserable [ __ ] son and I
am how quick it's like it's a really
hard lesson and then it dawned on me
that I thought about how much I loved
her and the reason why I will go over
there is because love is feeling pain
and doing it anyway and when I realized
that I realized that endurance is love
and that the more you feel love the more
you can endure something and as I this
[ __ ] plant has the most visceral way
of teaching you lessons that you don't
want to learn about the world that you
don't want to be in and I came back and
now like we had a conversation after
that in that it all stemmed around what
emotional qualities are we looking for
and what today what do they elicit out
of somebody like why why are you able to
connect with people that do certain
activities and don't do certain
activities and it's it's really informed
like if people are afraid of
psychedelics in my world I almost am NOT
interested in having conversations with
them because that fear shows and it
doesn't mean you have to use them it's
this fear of change that I see are you
afraid that you're gonna be somebody
different and if you are why are you
afraid of change like why do you not
want to be somebody different you've
experienced you up until this point and
it's gotten you to this point but why
wouldn't you want to shift that around
to see what else you can learn or what
else you can become so it is it's kind
of wacky or somedays I like it let us
say the the main the thing that I keep
on coming back to is posting out a
podcast or posting out a symposium this
is the team behind the 300 movie and you
know Henry Cavill and then you get
ayahuasca and and why the heat death of
the universe is how really it's just
entropy man and it's waves and yeah
you're at the bottom of a squat but
really really what I want to know is
have you managed to strip away the ego
it's like 400 pounds I
you back look look I I get the
impression that we could go on for I
could keep doing this all night
unfortunately I gotta go run a club
night but um man as soon as the
endurance things I mean I've got a list
I'm just looking at my notes I've got
all of the questions about fitness this
was a conversation not about fitness
that's what I'm gonna title this podcast
a conversation not about fitness well
it's been really good if there's
anything else maybe I'll send you the
endurance manual once we have it you
have the strength manual right no I'll
send you a copy that - thank you uh yeah
for sure - then you can kind of see
about it if we're having a symposium we
switch the UK one we're having a
symposium in Salt Lake City I don't know
your schedules like you're more than
welcome to come out for it it's a be
ended last weekend it may think it's a
30th and 31st it's a special one because
we we have some friends at Red Bull and
that morning before we start the
symposium we actually buy a baby
ayahuasca retreat with Red Bull I wish
the future I don't think we can
advertise that quite yet but we actually
run the Red Bull 400 beforehand which is
up in Park City which is the basically a
competition don't run up this ski jump
and it is cool terribly fun and also
transformative in its own way so that
one is a really special event we do that
every year
wait I'll go that they want to come and
fly out and see you all there in Utah
already where do they had to get
information on that our website is
nonprofit with a pH so Noa and PR o ph
ET dot media is the website we have all
our stuff all our goodies all our books
all ER symposiums are up there listed so
then there's you know loads of articles
I think we have like a hundred journal
articles I've been I do these micro
essays once a week for the past two
years so there's quite a bit of writing
out there for free the people gives
people an idea of what we're about now
holders work written teeth on Instagram
yes spec written teeth on Instagram
don't find me there I don't respond
great
but I have sometimes to put pictures or
whatever so ya find all those spots and
then whenever you want to redo this
maybe you come out to Salt Lake we'll
have you in our podcast that sounds
awesome
look thank you so much Michael I
appreciate that you don't often come on
podcast and I'm really glad that much to
get you on this one I think everything
that we've spoken about will be linked
in the show notes below the Sam Harris
thing the Paul bloom conversation Mike
chat with Aubrey Marcus any stuff that
Michael sends me over once we're
finished and of course a link to
nonprofit and despite the fact that he's
desperately trying to hide away on
social media Michaels Instagram I found
you on Twitter as well it's like some
handle and I should I want to track you
down on Twitter as well swarms of black
to black yeah it's just so yeah all of
your all of your social media handles
sound like emo songs from the mid-2000s
funny nuts weren't black was the black
dahlia murder song yeah super death
metal I used to be super into it never
changed it I didn't use Twitter still I
really like Twitter got you well I'll
put that in there as well look Michael
son thank you so much for your time I
really appreciate it it's been a it's
been illuminating and interesting and I
genuinely wish that we could continue it
hopefully we will in the future thank
you
[Music]
you